chief meteorologist Eric Fischer of our
Boston station WBZ is here tracking the
storms direction right now Eric good
morning good morning or good morning
everybody right now at the epicenter of
the strongest winds heaviest rain is
around the Jacksonville area in a very
dangerous situation there you notice the
shape of the storm as these tend to move
north they become more lopsided the
heaviest rain strongest winds on that
northeast side and in Jacksonville over
a foot of rainfall a flash flood
emergency in downtown Jacksonville for
that st. Johns River continues to rise
you have the heavy rain but also a
record storm surge so the river can't
flow out to the ocean and that's why we
have a serious issue there this morning
the latest at 75 mile-per-hour winds
it's moving north-northwest at 18 and
what we're seeing in Jacksonville is
going to be moving up toward the Georgia
coastline they're gusting over 60 miles
per hour right now so here's a look at
the track e will weaken to a tropical
storm but there's really no such thing
as just a tropical storm even if you get
60 mile-per-hour winds that would be
good enough for a severe thunderstorm
warning so that will cause a number of
power outages today you can expect the
strongest influence from that storm
along and north and east of the center
so across Georgia even into Atlanta
we'll see wind gusts over 50 miles per
hour power outages there for today and
we add in the rainfall there you see the
highest total southeast Georgia northern
Florida we've got another six inches of
rain in spots maybe up to 10 inches of
rain before things wind down Gail got it
Eric thank you